[inaudible] we just finished
watching Mr. Holmes.
So based on a novel,
a slight trick of mind by Mitch Colon,
Mr. Holmes reimagined Sherlock Holmes
as a real person who's adventures have
been turned into bestselling novels by
his friend and partner, Dr. John Watson,
now old and failing and health.
The famously rational detective is forced
to engage for the first time with his
emotions as his mental powers dwindle.
So I loved it.
I thought it was very, very good.
Um, and both of you, gosh, you're,
you're acting awards, your
accolades go on. I've got, you know,
I could print pages of these
things. I mean, you're not so much
where'd you do get them? They
do Google. Do not use it.
So what, what drew you to both to, to
this film? What was so unique about it?
The money. Okay. Or lack of it.
You've heard of independent movies?
Translated means cheap.
Well, I'm an, I'm sorry,
I've started talking first.
It's a, it's a wonderful
part. And, and the,
and the actor of my generation would have
jumped at the chance to play Sherlock
Holmes in his prime and then Sherlock
Holmes and his decline. I mean, you know,
two performances and in
the same film it's um,
it's a bit like doing a Gandalf the
grey and Gandalf, the white. Yeah,
they're the same but different and uh,
so that,
but
Laura will tell you the script arrives
and it says it's from bill con don it
your life stops while you recover,
breath and then you opened it and know
you're good to say yes because it's bill
and who we both worked
with a very happily,
I think both been number
that initially that
my feeling is if it's,
if a script looks like a film or
play that I would like to see,
then I then I get intrigued. If I
read something on that, I think I,
I really wouldn't want to go and
see that then I don't get involved.
But in this case,
the thing, Laura, same for you. First off,
it was bill Condon, who is,
you know, our, our friend and,
and director and there certain
directors who you will do anything for.
You have such good experiences working
with them that they whisper your name and
you will show up for two lines.
I mean,
not you do you do anything for them and
bill is certainly one of those people.
So it was bill in combination with,
right. You know, and
then on top of that,
Sherlock Holmes,
and I've been a Sherlock Holmes
fanatic since I was a child. So, um,
so the comp those three and it was
filmed in England for God's sake.
So all of those things
combined, it was just, you know,
kind of too good to be
true. The money though. No.
Yes. So you said you, I'm here we are.
We're doing this for free. God bless.
All right. Because we want you all to see
this room and you've seen it for free.
The beyond this particular
audience. Um, yeah. You,
you don't go around talking about a
film that you haven't enjoyed making an,
haven't enjoyed watching. Uh, we vote.
We both feel strongly
about it and I love it.
Well, you said, Laura, you said yes.
You said that you were a big
Sherlock Holmes Fan since
childhood, right? Right. So,
so bill Condon comes to you. You weren't
planning on doing anything for a right?
No, I, I had a baby a year and
a half ago. Oh, I'm such a baby.
A sweet little boy who's madly
in love with Anne. And I, uh,
Bill came over to meet the baby and we
spend a little time together and he said,
so what do you think you're going to
go back to work? I said, well, I'm not,
I have no plans. And he goes, okay. Okay.
And then the next day I got
an offer to do the movie.
I wasn't planning on going back to work,
but you know, for bill and you know, I,
I, I, you know,
got myself off the couch and strap the
baby to myself and we flew to London and
that was that. So did you know what
Ian was attached to it beforehand?
Was that part of the decision or would
you have taken it otherwise? Well,
it was certainly an added bonus because
Ian and I have been sort of fond
acquaintances for maybe 20 years,
but have never really spent any time
together other than through our mutual
friend Armistead muffin.
So,
and we were both in the television version
of [inaudible], right? I mean, yeah.
So,
um,
I've played a tiny part in one of the
episodes and we didn't meet, but yeah,
technically live work.
Yeah. So we've known each other through,
through Arma said for a very long time.
So I was just happy to be able to have
the opportunity to claim him as my own
friends, which I was able to do.
So that's been a real joy. Well,
you've both been nominated for Academy
Awards when films you've done with bill
Condon. So did that have any part,
like I guess you're friends with,
with bell from long time ago and you've
worked with them and God than monster is
years and years back. Um, so how much,
how much did working with bill have in
your head towards your decision in coming
on to this bill? Oh, it was,
um,
you okay. You, you, you,
you wouldn't want to play a wonderful
part unless you felt there was something
going to guide you. Right? Yeah. Good
par. Part of the wonderful part is,
is that you're not exactly certain that
you've got to be able to play it. And, uh,
yeah.
If you are,
you're going to need help
and bill's there to help.
Did you approach this as two completely
different characters? Like the,
there's the,
the real life Sherlock Holmes who's
aging and frail and then there's actual,
I drew that
for the man.
Well, the vet, they are, they're the same
person. They've got the same name of the,
the, the sort of look alike, but one is
in his prime and one is in its decline.
And, uh, it's not as difficult as it,
but there's the,
there's the Sherlock Holmes in his prime,
that doctor that Dr. Watson has painted
him to be. And then when he actually is,
so there's in essence three different
characters. No. Oh, good. Sinking. Yes,
of course. You caught me certain
when a Sherlock Holmes said,
I'm nothing like the character that,
uh, uh, Watson portrayed the, that the,
that he's right. You may be wrong.
That's up for the oldest judgment.
Is that four characters,
there's a multilayered moving.
Yes, it was. So Mrs. Monroe,
the character has never appeared in any
Sherlock Holmes stories before. Have you,
did you enjoy that fact that you had
like a clean slate or would you have
preferred something to be there?
I didn't care one way or the other really.
It was, she's, she's, she's,
she's got spirit, this Monroe, you know,
and she's been through a lot and
she's tired and she's scared and she's
grieving and you know, there's just a
lot there to play. Right. You know, so,
and the fact that it's a new constellation
of people around a Sherlock Holmes
that we haven't seen it.
It's fun.
And uh, uh, it being a
British town, of course,
it concerned with class
social class and there's this,
there's a privileged man,
right.
Homes just taking advantage of is
Brian and his capacity for hard work.
That's true. But you're just feel life
hasn't been too difficult for him too,
to find himself in the position where
he can be fulfilled but pour owed a
working cold.
No.
Oh
No,
I got it absolutely wrong.
So it was a lot of makeup
for Mrs. Monroe. Uh, yeah.
Doesn't have the advance.
You just had to make her own way.
And she's a widow and she's got
a a little boy. She loves him.
It's just trying to do, trying to do
her best but against the odds. And so,
yeah,
and the fact that this takes place
after the war and thinking about all of
the women who were war widows and what
that did to an entire generation
of women who lost their husbands,
who then all of a sudden
had to be employed and in
areas that maybe they weren't
qualified for. I mean, misses
Monroe's not the greatest housekeeper.
She's clearly not a good cook and
she doesn't enjoy it. You know,
that these women found themselves having
to do things out of desperation in
order to support themselves. And, and if
they were lucky enough to have children,
um, you know, they had to raise
their children on their own. So it's,
and I had never sort of a why I had never
thought about that, but I, but I hadn't,
you know, that whole, and all those
women who then had to, they had to move,
they had to migrate.
They couldn't stay where they were.
They had to give up their homes. They, you
know, it was a, it was not an easy time.
I lived in the north of England and his
relative to safe parts of the country
during the Second World War.
Uh, and we, we had, um, uh,
did they call evacuees a mother
and two kids came up from London.
That's the husband behind a firefighter.
And they just came and lived
with us for a year stored.
One of things that we did,
uh,
and homes has just gone through the wall.
He wouldn't know that the war it happened.
As far as he's concerned,
he's just been, I've just be, his husband
lives come to an end.
And what does he do?
He goes off to Japan not to investigate
the Hiroshima that comes in as a
surprise to them that they'll,
that used to give you some,
that they plan to keep himself alive. He's
a really, really, really selfish purse.
Right. Uh, and so
I think, I think Mr Monroe's bitterness
is absolutely understandable, but
homes is, selfishness is not right. Uh,
and it's nice. Moran, it's a tad isn't it?
At the end they come together,
she gets some sort of security.
She gets her son's love back as it were,
and um,
and homes discovers that he's got a
heart and then they hold hands done.
So speaking of, of the family unit, what
was it like working with Milo Parker?
He's a 10 at the time,
right?
I think it might've been 11. I'm not, I
don't, I'm not quite sure. He's a dcis.
Tiny, sweet sprite of a boy. And
uh, he is, he's just adorable.
He's got that face and um,
Oh god, that face that,
that face that can look very, very old and
very, very young at the time, you know,
and he's, you know, I've been very
lucky in that. I've worked with,
I don't know about you, but I've worked
with wonderful children. You know,
there's that old saying never. We don't
work with animals and children and, and I,
I've really loved the,
the kids that I've worked with and my
low is from a wonderful family and has,
comes to,
came to work everyday cheerful and wanting
to learn and happy to be there. And,
and uh, you know, I had
a great phone with Milo.
You flirted a lot with the makeup
roommate.
If anybody in the audience has questions
a step up to these mikes. We're,
we're running a little short on time
so we can cut to the audience Q and a
pretty quickly here. Um,
yeah, watching, watching Milo,
I believe. Uh, it's always,
it's always so interesting to me because
I feel like with a child actor with a
story this deep that,
that children, children,
actors and maker can make or break a
story for me because they're either like
indicating or they're being the
character, right? So I think he did.
There's no question here.
I'm just telling you,
I think he did an extremely good job.
He did. And I'm, uh, I will say, and I
hope if Marla, which are here, the, she,
he wouldn't take it wrong.
You know, when you're acting,
you concerned with yourself that, that
that's it. That's your responsibility.
You shouldn't be worrying
about other people.
And what I was worried about Milo,
cause I,
although I was getting the performance
and he was responding and doing what was
suggested and I thought,
I don't see this performance is really
quite as vibrant lit on the moment as it
should be. Well, I was wrong
and I shouldn't demean bothering him out,
man.
I should have been getting on with my,
my own performance and
learn something from that.
So I was surprised when I saw
it. Uh, it was the same one, a,
a great English actress,
Sibyl Thorndyke who did very few firms
but was in Nazi Olivier's film called the
sleeping prince, I think, or something
like that with Marilyn Monroe, Monroe.
I did these,
are these names familiar to you or not?
Yeah.
Not Simple Song. No. Perhaps, but a
certain amount of Monroe and that she was
Sundeck sands two friends and the dreaded,
but this woman can't act.
I'm talking about Marilyn Monroe.
She's not giving you a performance.
I can't hear this absolute disaster.
And she saw the firm and realized that
her own performance was the disaster
because it was too big for
the camera. The, the genius,
which was a of the relationship
between Marlyn Monroe and the camera,
which unmatched really had passed by.
Uh, even the Eagle. I have an, uh,
an experienced actor and I've,
I'm afraid it was a bit like
that with me and Myla. Anyway,
he's a star now. He's working
with Spielberg, isn't it? Yeah.
Okay.
Sure. Thank you both so much for being
here. I really enjoyed the film. Uh,
and fun fact,
whenever I'm asked the question of if
you were to have lunch with one living
person, um, it's there,
Ian Mckellen. So I'm like
my one, uh, I think
back to when I was a musician in high
school and I had these moments that I
would call really poignantly
memorable, um, during a performance,
whether it was a certain string of music
or a certain or a certain piece that
gave me kind of, you know, Google apps
on the IPAD. I have a checkered past.
I played the Tuba for many years.
There was an orchestra and I had these
moments and I was wondering if each of
you would share a moment in your
acting career where, you know,
you may refer back to a scene that you
performed in and every time you watch it
you get those, you know, hairs on
the back of your neck stand up.
That was something that was very
poignantly memorable to you.
I can't stand to watch myself. Oh yeah.
I just, I just can't, I can't take it.
Or how about in the moment of that
in memory of the theater is, is,
is it totally different
situation. Um, I just,
I have a very hard time watching myself.
I love watching everybody
else in the movie, but I'm
the, um, but for memories of,
of being the theater, there's
a bunch of them, you know,
and they don't happen very often,
but when they do,
and they usually happen within like
ten second periods of feeling like, oh,
that everything aligns perfectly. And
there's this wonderful sense of system of,
of suspense where you've completely
stopped working on the play and the place
completely working on
you and it served as,
carries you through in a
way of really is thrilling.
And I did a production of the crucible
with Liam Neeson and I think they did.
I have wonderful memories of that.
That's my answer.
Yeah. Well, the film
close to my heart, uh,
is one that I
helped to write over the age of William
Shakespeare, but she's the said that,
and I also produced it.
And without my efforts it wouldn't,
we wouldn't have raised
the funds to make it.
And so I [inaudible] I hadn't at that
point really played much within a success
for the cinema. Um, I,
I did have the idea that the first,
the opening speech of
the play on the film,
uh,
now as the winter of our discontent
made glorious summer by the Son of York
should be a public speech,
uh, to his brother,
uh, newly made king. And of course
he wants to be king himself, Richard,
but we don't know that is
not in those opening lines.
And halfway through that
rather than long speech,
I knew from having paid it in the theater,
there was a t a change in tone.
The public speech suddenly turns private.
I met the owners.
Shakespeare could do this. Yeah. I mean,
you catch your breath when you're doing
it every night and you realize this is
the moment when you got to take the whole
audience into your insides and, and,
and, and uh, let them
know that. All right.
And I had the idea that
that halfway through
the speech in the movie,
we would go from the public situation
to enter the most private place of all
really,
which is the place where you urinate.
So suddenly in the middle of the
speech, uh, the public man is,
he's,
he's deformed his undoing his
flies and having a pee and when I,
every time I see it, and I don't say that
up, but I think what I'm really excited
yeah.
Sit on my a website I think.
Yeah.
Over here.
Um,
I have a question on how much leverage
do as an actor do you have of changing
things in the script? For example,
like along the movie we learn that hey,
show homes learns that logic alone doesn't
really solve the problem it solves in
on paper,
but not really salt because the woman
died and the husband was really angrily
looking at homes and homes feels guilt
and related that he hasn't really solved
the case.
So in when he went homes does is isn't
quite the contrary to what you would
probably expect an like
Sherlock Holmes to do.
I would like Sherlock Holmes to say,
Hey,
I learned something to do and
apply it to a new case rather than,
that kind of like was a let down
for me. Like, hey home. So the hero,
like I was like thinking
of that and they're, oh no,
why is he on get taking on so much guilt
and running away from everything? Um,
as an actor, if I just say hi, did
you get the script and say, Hey,
I'm not going to play this home,
so I'll probably going to change it.
He should be a hero.
Well, I started acting, uh,
and I've gone on acting with
total respect for the script.
Uh,
that's all you have to say.
Yeah. I mean, we are acting.
We, we don't initiate it
really rare circumstances.
We rather do anyway.
And if you're dealing with Shakespeare,
this is the map the master.
And if it's checkoff Anton Chekhov,
even in translation, these,
these are the words, this is what you
have to play with. And it must have this,
if you're doing a play by a, a new,
uh, a new play or an old play much,
the authors long dead,
you must rehearse it with the assumption
that any minute now he might come back
from the bathroom and say,
what you doing?
And that being, so that's my
training, uh, that, that site,
it's the same one. I read the
script, the other film. No Way.
Okay.
Do I have confidence that
I could contribute anything
to a script that's been
gone over maybe for two,
three or four years by a writer?
Uh,
and
however Lord of the Rings I,
I had to, I had him my,
uh, pocket. Sure. Out.
And sometimes when I'm striding
across Middle East, the, the, the,
the GAM catches and you could
see that inside here is the,
the big thick three volume
paperback at Lord of the Rings.
Because I was always referring to it.
[inaudible] seem to be detraction,
not you've missed out a line here that
I never got my own way. And uh, uh,
and I did point out to him that a Gandalf
in the book never says you shall not
pass.
He says you cannot pass.
It's not as good as it.
So we have time for one
last question over here.
I know,
I know.
So I guess my question is kind of serious
and now I feel bad that it's the last
one.
One other, there's one other person behind
her. Okay. We did two more questions.
Yeah. Do you talk to your
people? I'm okay with that.
I was just wondering,
uh,
so Siri and in the movie you're playing
like Sherlock who's like a bit older
than you are like 20 years
older than you or something.
Yes.
Uh,
sorry.
I was just wondering if like playing
characters who are like pretty old and I
thought Sherlock was going to die,
if that like gives you any
sort of existential crises
or if it's
because that's how I would react.
I Dunno.
What was the question?
Did playing someone old make
you existentially scared?
I find the older I get, the
less scared I got. I've had,
I'm not scared of dying. I'm
dying is a part of life, isn't it?
Okay.
I'm frank to solves up lots of promise,
but you know, I just, dude, I don't
have you died a lot as an actor.
Not a lot. No, but as you get
older, you'll know. Yeah, no,
I'm died twice that I can think of. Yeah,
there you go. Don't do it. There's more,
more troubled marriages that I've
done a lot of time, but I've,
but I've died twice, but I, I've
done quite a lot. And it's a puzzle.
It's a puzzle just to what to do
because I haven't actually seen.
And the body and the animal
die.
Well, we've all seen
actress dying. I'm it.
And I think what would be wonderful to do
on stage is for you to sync.
Got The actor has died.
It just managed to say the last line
of the part and then didn't year die on
stage. Did he? Yeah, I think so. Yeah.
And um, I ran, Ryan died
onstage. Few people of it. Yeah.
But the trick of it would be that he
hasn't really died, but he was holding it.
Okay.
I did. I did see a David
Bradley and the road shows
national sales or production of Henry
the fourth part, two by Shakespeare.
And he's playing the old king.
How does she mom seen long specie and
who said that he had to a day he had to
die now. So he leaves the
stage to die. And I don't,
I'm witnessing my friend David Bradley,
he's dying,
not going to make it to
the wings. Um, when they,
when the Messenger came and
said the king is dead. Oh Wow.
That's wonderful,
isn't it?
Maybe you imagine if we could
act height that all the time.
Guess the answer your question.
Does that answer your question?
All right now for real.
Last question.
Okay, thanks. I just love this
film so much. It was so good.
And one of the things that blew me away
and I'm going to have to go away and
think about is all the levels that we
saw of both reality and the direction of
the narrative. Because Laura,
your part, you were the beginning,
the middle and end in what was the
films present time. And Sir Ian,
you were had a nonlinear existence and
you had to decide for yourself as an
actor what was real and what was not.
So I guess are those things that that
drew you to this and and in condoms work
you see this a lot like in
gods and monsters as well.
There's what is reliable about
memory and how do you deal with that?
Sure. Hi. Good. That's
why she has a playwright
that's play right now. Yeah. Yeah. Uh,
it's, um, it's, um,
bill condoms, men for movers. I can
just think off the top of my head.
Got Gods and monsters. Uh, Kinzie.
Um, the, um, um, uh,
sounds moving on the fifth
estate. Yes. This the state.
Uh,
and now Mr. Holmes,
I'm the essential cat is brilliant,
uniquely, uh, achieving.
And I bet mad
bill wants to know where that comes from.
Funny isn't it?
And Amanda who likes nothing better
than to a director, a musical. I mean,
he's doing a beauty and the beast
and the iron minutes. I play a clock,
but I'm this, I'm that matter of,
of memory that, that, that has all,
all the parts of it.
And A, I don't know. Um,
I'm not sure I could, I
could answer it. There's,
there's something amazing
when you work in this is,
I think one of the reasons
why we love working with bell.
We can look at a script,
which is sort of like a blueprint for us.
It sort of like an architect who does a
blueprint, a score for musicians. It's,
it's sort of the basic thing that we
then go into and we try and are our brain
sort of works like chess people.
We can sort of look through it the way
that someone who's playing chess can go
from move to move to move to move.
But what bill does is that he has not
only a narrative mind and an understanding
of the technicalities of film
production and also what actors do,
but he has a cinematic mind and I am
constantly amazed at how he tells a story
cinematically and thematic Lee is this
stuff that you've just, and how he ties,
you know,
the visual and the the thematic together.
And that's what really great
filmmakers do. And it's always sort of,
I mean cause we're not aware that that's
happening when we're working on it.
You know, when you see we work at
scene to scene, to scene, to scene,
and we have our own arcs and we see,
you know,
hopefully you think beyond your own
arc and how does my character help this
character move into the next scene and
all those sorts of things. But then I,
and then when you actually see a movie
that's visually also told in the way that
only film can do, you know, it's really,
you're like, oh my God, I had no idea.
That was like, wow. So, and
that's certainly, you know,
this movie was the first time
I saw it. You know, it's,
it's so visually beautiful.
Beautiful. So it's, it's uh, it's
been a joy to be a part of. Yay.
Yeah.
Before we say goodbye [inaudible]
can I say something please? No,
nothing to do with Mr Hubs.
Okay.
Um,
when that, when that,
when that was a land, mmm.
And I wanted to know something.
Okay.
Uh,
a fact or
a definition perhaps
definition is relatively easy.
Yeah.
Because we have a dictionary.
My dictionary at home is one of the,
my most precious
possessions. I, I love it.
Read it again
about something that I couldn't access
at home and we had lots of books that
have,
I would catch a bus
into town,
the number two or the number four
and hope I got the times right and go
to the library and it'd be a reference
library of course.
And I would stand in line there,
Joe speaking alive,
everything was conducted in whispers,
have you got to book,
come sit down.
So I'd sit down and 15 minutes later she
would have done her job and she would
have gone and collected a series of
books which she thought might concern the
answer to my question and their
beer, you know, a pile of books.
And I think there's some times brought
on a trolley and I was given a desk and I
was allowed to sit at it. And I'm
speaking, no marking the books of course,
no indication, no little posted, most new,
we just had to go through these books
and maybe I'm the seventh book outward,
find what I was looking for.
Hmm.
And then I had to catch the bus back home.
Google.
It's the biggest change in my life.
Uh, and it's a change, I think,
without any regrets,
except you never have the joy
of doing all the work yourself.
You know, when you finally get
that in the book and there it is
and it's yours, you'll
never, ever, ever forget it.
Those are the people who do all the words.
[inaudible]
do you go to the light,
ladies and gentlemen?
Laura Linney and Sir Ian McKellen.
[inaudible].